say
when i got this role
i never imagined
how my life would change not only
because of the creative experience but
even more because of the personal
experience and the relationship that i
forged with leonard and the relationship
that he fostered and nurtured
in the last eight years of his life when
i was so fortunate enough to be a part
of it
and now that he's gone
i feel even more grateful that that
relationship has led me to my
relationship with his family and i love
them like my own and they've been so
incredible and carry on his spirit in
such beautiful ways and they are
so wonderful and they're all here
tonight so many of them here tonight his
wife susan his stepson aaron his son
adam his daughter
his grandkids
and
it really is um this is like i don't
know this is just such an incredible
moment because i know that so many other
young actors in the future are going to
be stumbling their way around this lot
and leonard will guide them
in the way that he guided me
and
he'll do that because we are about to
unveil
and it is a great honor and my privilege
to officially open at paramount studios
leonard nimoy way so let's raise a glass
and hold them in our hearts
now
yeah
[Applause]
i said raise the glass all right
you did you guys are all witnessing a
little bit of history right here and you
are now going to be part of the
historical record of that if you all
look up at the scissor lift you can't
see past the lights here we're taking a
photo commemorating it so everyone look
up and say knee boy
[Applause]
well played
okay now uh take a look here you are in
front of stage 32 another